sie wollten gerade ich ich habe sie
vorhin kurz zitiert diesen Tweet glaube
ich war es sie sagten das klang für mich
sehr sehr wütend und sauer sie sagt es
kann auch nicht ernsthaft sein dass du
immer wieder weiter diese Platte
abspielt da gibt es ein paar arme
abgehängte Leute und die sind frustriert
und unverstanden und der ganze Osten und
jetzt sollen wir endlich mal zuhören und
um Euch zu ärgern wählen wie jetzt
einfach mal die AFD und am Ende sind
dann alle Schuld die Ampel und die CDU
und das Wetter und keine Ahnung was aber
seltsamerweise die AFD will er nicht das
sprach sehr viel Frustration aus diesem
Text
ich bin angefasst ich bin politisch groß
geworden mit einer Gewissheit wir sind
irgendwie natürlich europäischer
Mainstream aber an einem sind wir in
Deutschland
sensibel das ist sensibel gegenüber
Nationalismus
demokratieverachtung Populismus und ich
habe auch gerade nach den jüngsten
Diskussionen in Deutschland den Eindruck
dass wir eigentlich
bis Wein froh zu sein scheinen in diesem
europäischen Mainstream angekommen zu
sein also wir haben eine lange
rechtfertigungs war da Menschen die ich
ernst nehme in ihrem Wahlverhalten und
das ist keine wählerbeschimpfung ich
nehme die einfach nur ernst
haben eine Entscheidung getroffen und
jetzt lange zu überlegen wieso weshalb
warum die AFD wählen überall in
Deutschland natürlich auch in meinem
Wahlkreis nicht nur in Thüringen nicht
nur in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern nicht nur
in Sachsen na klar ist das eine ganz
gesamtdeutsche Phänomen aber wir müssen
schon zur Kenntnis nehmen warum wählen
ungefähr doppelt so viele
prozentual gesehen in Ostdeutschland die
AFD wie in Westdeutschland ich habe
darauf keine abschließende Frage
gefunden Antwort keine abschließende
Antwort gefunden aber ich finde dieses
diese diese diese Automatismus wir
müssen uns jetzt stärker kümmern wir
müssen zuhören wir müssen uns der sorgen
annehmen so als seien wir ein Armenhaus
mit ganz vielen sozialen Problemen die
ich überhaupt nicht kleinreden möchte
aber am Ende des Tages wird hier
Freiheit gering geschätzt wird hier
Demokratie klein geredet und natürlich
gibt es auch Anti-Amerikanismus vor
allem auch bei mir zu Hause das ist ja
auch ein Phänomen der Linken aber es
gibt schon auch eine gewisse Bewunderung
für einen vermeintlich starken Mann der
so auf dem Tisch haut und der sich um
diesen ganzen Firlefanz der Demokratie
nicht kümmern muss und ich möchte ganz
einfach Wählerinnen und Wähler ernst
nehmen und deswegen stört mich an der
Diskussion manches ich möchte nicht so
weit gehen wie der Historiker aus
Ostdeutschland der kürzlich in der
Tatsachen
Nazis wählt ist ein Nazi so weit möchte
ich nicht gehen Sie auf die
Kommunalpolitik hinweisen und ich bin
ein ich bin in der Kommunalpolitik groß
geworden und ich mir dann Sonnenberg
anschaue wo es keine kommunalpolitischen
Themen auf den AFD Wahlplakaten gab
sondern es ging um eine Absage der
Sanktionen gegenüber Russland es ging um
eine Absage an der Beteiligung am Krieg
Verbrenner retten es ging um eine Absage
an weitreichende Klimaschutzmaßnahmen
und dann wurde auch noch gesagt naja es
haben ja nur so wenige gewählt in Hessen
gibt es keinen einzigen Landkreis in dem
mehr als 30 35 Prozent an einer
Landratswahl beteiligt waren in
Sonneberg haben deutlich über 50 Prozent
gewählt das ist ein für eine
Kommunalwahl für eine landratsdirekt
weil eine erstaunlich hohe Zahl und
wieder war der Punkt naja man muss ja
beachten die meisten haben ja überhaupt
oder viele haben ja gar nicht gewählt
die wollen das alle nicht und ich finde
dass wir uns dieser bitteren Wahrheit
stellen müssen dass es offensichtlich in
ganz Deutschland und in einigen Teilen
Deutschlands offenkundig mehr eine
verfestigte Verachtung gegenüber
Demokratie gibt eine Geringschätzung der
Freiheit also jetzt muss ich mal kurz
dazwischen gehen entschuldigen warum
also ist jetzt überhaupt nicht meine
Aufgabe AFD Wähler irgendwie in Schutz
zu nehmen das habe ich auch glaube ich
noch nie gemacht ist es eine
Geringschätzung der Demokratie wählen zu
gehen und eine Partei zu wählen die
ihnen nicht passt
ja weil ich will ja nicht irgendeine
Partei nicht wähle eine Partei die ganz
offen sagt dass sie diese Demokratie
verachtet die AFD in Thüringen ist nicht
irgendeine rechts populistische Partei
sie wird vom Verfassungsschutz als
durchgängig rechtsextreme eingestuft
Herr Höcker ist nur nicht irgendein sich
bürgerlich tarnen da afd-politiker ich
glaube er höcke symbolisiert auch den
faschistoiden Teil der AFD
und das macht mich sprachlos also
Thüringen ist schon ein Fall und ich bin
ja oft in Thüringen ist ja meine
Nachbarregion die mir auch am Herzen
liegt und ich habe jetzt keine
abschließenden Antworten noch einmal
aber ich kann nicht einfach so zur
Tagesordnung übergehen und sagen na ja
alles ganz schwierig und eigentlich wenn
wir jetzt in der Koalition weniger
streiten und wenn die CDU jetzt endlich
nicht diese narrative übernimmt dann ist
alles wieder gut und ich befürchte und
das ist nur mein Satz ich befürchte dass
es so einfach nicht sein wird
der höcke ja durchaus Erlebnis
politische
Bad soden-allendorf in meinem Wahlkreis
wo ich gestern noch Schülerinnen und
Schüler empfangen habe Lehrer macht
vielleicht auch deutlich also die der
war bei mir Lehrer und nicht in
Thüringen da ist er Politiker
also ich verstehe dass sie angefasst
sind das merkt man ihnen auch an es sind
viele in diese Region angefasst auch
viele die da zu Hause sind und denen das
nicht passt ist die AFD jetzt zum ersten
Mal ein Landrat stellt ich finde nur
also sie sie stellen es so da es wird
ein bisschen als würde sich das ganze
Land immer über AFD Wähler beugen und
fragen was fehlt euch denn warum geht es
euch nicht gut ich finde da blenden Sie
was aus eine gewisse AFD
wählerbeschimpfung gibt es ja seitdem
ist die AFD gibt also das was sie gerade
gemacht haben
so nachvollziehbar ich das finde ist ist
ja nicht so dass es zum ersten Mal im
deutschen Fernsehen gesagt worden wäre
sondern das hören wir seit ist die AFD
gibt warum wählt ihr diese Partei obwohl
sie rechtsextreme ist und so das ist ja
nichts Neues und ich glaube auch so wie
ich AFD Wähler kenne die wollen gar
nicht dass sie sich jetzt unbedingt
therapeutisch über die beugen ähm über
sie beugen sondern was fehlt euch denn
sondern die wollen die wollen die AFD
und machtvollen Position und in diese
Situation kommen sie jetzt sehr langsam
auch sie haben das erste Landratsamt
erobert so will ich mal nennen und ich
finde es ist schon die Aufgabe der
deutschen Volksparteien der SPD der CDU
aller etablierten Parteien sich die
Frage zu stellen wie kann man im Zweifel
wenn man ein Interesse daran hat die AFD
wieder zu schwächen wie wie kann einem
das Gelingen und es gelingt einem glaube
ich nicht indem man nur seine
Enttäuschung kundtut und sagt wie könnt
ihr nur ich glaube dann werden sie nicht
erfolgreich sein Sie können mir doch
jetzt nicht unterstellen dass ich nur
meiner Enttäuschung Ausdruck verliehen
habe ich habe erstmal versucht eine
Situation zu beschreiben und es geht ja
noch weiter in dieser Woche und in der
vergangenen Woche haben wir darüber
diskutiert den Medien dass man jetzt
endlich mal die AFD ernst nehmen müsste
man müsste sie einladen man müsste mit
ihr ernsthaft reden also ich nehme das
anders wahr ich höre die AFD in jeder
Sitzungswoche im Bundestag die können
dort ohne dass ihn jemand irgendwo den
Lautsprecher oder
machst was ausschaltet ihre Meinung
sagen die werden eingeladen die sind
Teil der öffentlichen Debatte die prägen
ja auch teilweise die Debatten wenn ich
mal das migrationsthema mir anschaue
also dieser Eindruck man müsste jetzt
endlich die auch mal ernst nehmen sie
müssen sich mit ihnen auseinandersetzen
verkennt doch die Tatsache dass die AFD
über viele Jahre hinwegschauen die
Diskussionen geprägt hat und ich bin
ganz bei Ihnen wenn Sie mich fragen wie
man damit umgeht ist aus meiner Sicht
Haltung zeigen auch bereit sein mit den
Leuten zu reden da wo man noch reden
kann und da wo man nicht gleich mit
Geringschätzung bestraft wird und ich
halte auch nichts davon jetzt die eigene
Agenda der afd-agenda anzupassen das ist
jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen verkürzt
aber das wären aus meiner Sicht ein paar
Angebote
ganz kurz ich saß eben hier sie haben
gerade
losgelegt sozusagen ja
auch nicht 0815 Thema ne ist es eben
Gottes
jeder sagt was immer möchte und ist auch
völlig in Ordnung sondern interessant
weil da sitzen drei Menschen von dem wir
gerade festgestellt haben sind alle in
Ostdeutschland geboren und es war
wirklich dieses Gefühl tut mich einmal
weg in Stuhl weil jetzt liegt wieder da
los und beschimpft uns alle habe ich
doch gar nicht nein aber ich habe das
Gefühl es ist so ein bisschen symbolisch
für das was was da teilweise so abläuft
ist es empfinden viele mit dem man
spricht wir sind keine Nazis wir sind
keine rechtsradikalen wir lassen uns
auch nicht über einen Kamm scheren haben
sie nicht gemacht mir geht zu meinen
Gefallen ostdeutschen Historiker zitiert
ja ja aber ich habe eben gerade gesagt
das ist etwas was mir so ungut
aufgestoßen ist dieser Tage brauner
Bodensatz das war der Begriff der
gefallen ist ich weiß nicht mehr von wem
in der Debatte
in Thüringen so der war das genau danke
dachte so kann man nicht reden sorry
geht nicht aber er holt sie urteilen
natürlich doch sehr stark und sie
urteilen aus ihrer rationalen Position
die ich weithin ja mit Sicherheit Teile
aber was wir in Ostdeutschland erleben
ist eben nicht unbedingt so auf dieser
rationalen Ebene so abbildbar bleiben
wir bei der AFD die AFD drängelt sich
mit ihren Themen in einer unverschämten
Art in die kommunale Landschaft hinein
ich erlebe es permanent im Kreistag Herr
höcke sitzt in meinem Kreistag ich bin
der Vorsitzende des Kreistages und ich
habe bei jeder Kreistagssitzung bei
jeder Wortmeldung erst einmal darauf
hinzuweisen bitte wir sind im eigenen
Wirkungskreis als Landkreis sind wir
eine Vertretungskörperschaft wir sind
kein Parlament bitte halten Sie sich
daran dass sie die Themen behandeln die
nach der kommunalordnung für uns
zuständig sind dann bekomme ich
Erklärungen dass ich doch im Namen der
Demokratie hier etwas großzügiger sein
müssen und dann muss ich mir doch so
fünf Minuten zehn Minuten so eine
Philippi car anhören die einfach nicht
in den Kreis hineingehören
und dort kommen große Themen können Sie
es einmal konkret machen ich finde das
weil das ist ein wahnsinnig interessante
Flüchtlingen natürlich und dann und vor
einer jeden Kreistagssitzung bekomme ich
eine lange Latte an Fragen zu alles zu
Themen die den Landkreis als
Gebietskörperschaft überhaupt nicht
berühren das sind Bundes und
landespolitische Themen und ich mache
dann immer deutlich erst also nach dem
und dem Paragraphen gehört das hier
nicht hin denn wir sind im eigenen
Wirkungskreis unterwegs und das sind
Themen des übertragenen Wirkungskreises
aber ich antworte dennoch inhaltlich wie
folgt aber es wird permanent werden
diese großen Themen in diese kleine
kommunale Welt hineingegeben das
entschuldigt nicht schon wieder der am
Ende
menschenverachtende Leute wählt das sind
wir vollkommen gemeinsam unterwegs und
trotzdem verteidige ich diese Menschen
weil ihnen ein Verhalten attestiert wird
im Ergebnis von mir aus ja aber es ist
nicht so gemeint es wird vielen eben
viele wehren sich auch mit es werden in
Themen aufgedrängt und natürlich sind
sie in Sonneberg dem Etikettenschwindel
erlegen gewesen dort kommen Leute und
erklären permanent wir können die Welt
aus den Angeln heben wenn ihr uns als
AFD wählt oder nehmen sie doch nur den
den Auftritt dann von dem neuen Kollegen
Sesselmann die mich persönlich wirklich
nun ist der der Landrat ich wünsche ihm
alles Gute zum Wohl von Sonneberg aber
was unerträglich ist dass er am Abend
seiner Wahl sich umgibt mit Partei
Leuten und Partei Leute feiern diesen
Sieg des Landrates als ihren sie das ist
unerträglich und das ist Hintergrund
weshalb ich sage möglicherweise sind wir
in Ostdeutschland für diese großen
Diskussionen auf der kommunalen Ebene
noch so nicht vorbereitet das sind wir
wahrscheinlich gar nicht auseinander
aber die Leute haben sich bisher in
Ihrer kommunalen Welt halt wegen gut
zurechtgefunden und jetzt drängt große
Politik im Nachhinein und die Leute
möchten ihr Leben festhalten wie es aber
so auch nicht fest haltbar ist und
vieles gehört am Ende des Tages zusammen
aber
man muss sehen
mein Rat ist ganz einfach wir brauchen
wieder viel mehr Transparenz in
Deutschland wir brauchen eine starke
Unterscheidung zwischen dem eigenen
Wirkungskreis und dem übertragenen
Wirkungskreis wir brauchen uns nur an
Recht und Gesetz zu halten da ist alles
drin aber in dem großen Impetus dass wir
alle über alles diskutieren können die
meisten ja am Ende alles in einen Topf
und die Leute machen ihre Kreuze dort wo
sie zumindest mir nicht gefallen
also ich finde wir müssen ein bisschen
gucken wofür wir die AFD kritisieren es
gibt sehr viel kritikwürdiges an dieser
Partei aber dass ich wahlgewinne an
einem Wahlamt mit ihren Parteifreunden
umgeben das ist eigentlich
bei allen Parteien so also
es gefällt mir nicht es gefällt ihnen
nicht aber ich weiß nicht ob es Sinn
macht sozusagen die AFD für etwas zu
kritisieren was alle anderen auch tun
was mich mehr umtreibt ist wenn wenn wir
jetzt von Sonneberg reden die AFD hat
eine relativ starke im ganzen Land
übrigens eine relativ starke
kernwählerschaft ich habe mir die
Umfragewerte der letzten fünf Jahre
angeschaut die sind bundesweit nie
geringer als 9 bis 10 Prozent ja die
haben Wähler die fest zu ihnen stehen
ich glaube auch weil sie von diesem
Kernprogramm der AFD und sie hat ja
einen inhaltliches Programm davon
überzeugt sind aber es gibt auch
Schwankungen und wenn wir uns
beispielsweise die Landratswahlen im
vorigen Jahren in Sachsen angucken dann
sehen wir was sehr interessant ist
Sachsen ist ein Kernland der nirgendwo
ist sie so stark wie da da ist sie bei
zwei Bundestagswahlen in folgestärkste
Kraft geworden in Sachsen ist es der AFD
in keinem einzigen Landkreis gelungen
den Landrat zu stellen vor einem Jahr
das hat ein bisschen was damit zu tun
dass die Regierung damals glaube ich
noch besser beieinander war was wir im
zurückliegenden Jahr erlebt haben ist
eine ampelregierung die sich nicht über
Kleinigkeiten zerstritten hat sondern
über die großen Reformprojekte also
wirklich Projekte von denen wir alle
wissen die sind relevant die verändern
das ganze Land da muss man lange drüber
nachdenken bevor man an die
Öffentlichkeit geht die gasumlage das
heizgesetz den Atomausstieg wir haben
aber keine Regierung erlebt die sich
intern geeinigt hat und dann mit einem
Vorschlag an die Öffentlichkeit gegangen
ist und den zu diskutieren sondern eine
Regierung die sich über jedes zentrale
Vorhaben öffentlich regelrecht zerfetzt
hat und ich glaube dabei ist der
Eindruck entstanden auch bei WLAN die
nicht so gern Wählerschaft von von der
AFD gehören die sind überfordert die
kriegen das nicht hin und wer den
Eindruck hat die sind vielleicht nicht
mehr kompetent genug sowohl die
Regierung als auch die CDU Opposition da
neigt dann eben dazu statt Nichtwähler
zu sein diesmal der AFD ihr sein Kreuz
zu geben oder eben sich für die AFD zu
entscheiden obwohl er sonst manchmal SPD
oder beispielsweise CDU gewählt hat Frau
Packung weiß jetzt völlig zu Recht
darauf hin das ist eine Entwicklung die
es eben nicht nur in Ostdeutschland gibt
ne man macht er sich viel zu einfach
wenn man sagt diesen Aufstieg gibt es
nur in Ostdeutschland dann gibt es auch
in Westdeutschland
sie haben gerade gesagt Henning
Etikettenschwindel ich fand ich sehr
interessant Kollegen aus meins die haben
eine Umfrage gemacht in Sonneberg und
ich glaube die Kollegen aus der Regie
haben das Vorliegen einmal kurz
reinhören das spürt man das dieses
dieses zerrissen sein und auch
verstanden haben die fühlen uns
eigentlich an der Nase rum weil die
versprechen uns Dinge die können sie gar
nicht halten der ein oder andere hat
geblickt unter anderem hat ganz klare
Gründe warum man das Kreuzchen genau bei
dieser Partei gemacht hat mich noch mal
kurz rein einfach nur froh dass man eine
von der AFD an der Macht ist
mir eigentlich nur ich finde halt ja die
wir haben hier ganz viele Schilder zum
Beispiel und das ist halt einfach
ansprechend also mich spricht es an
bitte den Handwerk tätig und das ist
genau das was ich eigentlich hören
möchte und was mich interessiert und der
andere Bullshit hat mich halt nicht so
wirklich interessiert keine Ahnung
gewählt
und wenn es jetzt der Herr Sesselmann
als neue Landrat ist sollte man das
akzeptieren also ich bin erschüttert
eine Rechtspartei kann man nicht wählen
er hat ja sich eigentlich zu
Kommunalpolitik gar nicht geäußert und
wird aber trotzdem hier gewählt und sich
ja permanent eigentlich zur Bundes-
das kann man ja hier eh nicht wählen es
kann doch gar keiner hier beeinflussen
für unsere Leute ist kein Geld
naja aber das ist genau der
Etikettenschwindel es wird suggeriert
der Landrat könne all die Themen die die
Leute ärgern ändern und das ist eine
Lüge und das ist meine Kritik an dem
neuen Kollegen Sesselmann dass er es
zugelassen hat und dass er selbst vorne
weggegangen ist und gesagt hat wir mit
der AFD wir werden es ändern ich will
mich noch nicht einmal mit der AFD als
Partei befassen das soll jeder für sich
tun aber es ist einfach falsch zu meinen
der Landrat in Sonneberg könne mit Hilfe
der AFD grundlegend Dinge ändern er ist
recht und Gesetz unterworfen und er muss
Recht und Gesetz einhalten und dafür
gibt es eine Rechtsaufsicht und das was
man über ihn haben will kann man über
ihn nicht bekommen und da ist meine
Kritik Kritik das hätte er nicht tun
dürfen dass er sagt wenn ihr mich wählt
dann bin ich bereit und mit Herrn höcke
im Gepäck werde ich das alles lösen das
ist falsch
es wird rauskommen
ist irgendwann im ersten auffallen dass
er das gar nicht sie wollten und dann
wollte ich Frau Paarung machen
also was mir noch mal wichtig ist in der
Diskussion es ist nicht alleine und in
erster Linie eine ost-west-diskussion
weil die Erfahrungen in Europa zeigen
dass die ersten Aufschläge in Ländern
kommen die eine schmerzhafte
transformationserfahrung gemacht haben
und das ist natürlich in Ostdeutschland
im Gegensatz zu Westdeutschland der Fall
aber deswegen bin ich vielleicht besorgt
da als der eine oder die andere
das wird vor Westdeutschland über kurz
oder lang nicht halt machen und das
zeigen ja auch die Erfahrung das heißt
jetzt schon nicht ich will hier kein
Ostdeutschland basing betreiben sondern
ich frage mich was können wir aus diesen
Entwicklungen die möglicherweise in
Ostdeutschland quantitativ etwas früher
sind als in Westdeutschland lernen dass
diese freiheitliche Demokratie diese
offene Gesellschaft einfach nicht kaputt
geht und das ist für mich ein
emotionales Thema und das zweite was mir
immer wichtig ist und dann mag es einen
distance geben
ich bin immer gut damit gefahren
Wählerinnen und Wähler in ihrer Wahl
Entscheidung ernst zu nehmen
und es sind manchmal nur Kleinigkeiten
die Menschen motivieren die eine oder
die andere Partei zu wählen aber und das
ist dann vielleicht wieder der discence
für mich ist eben die AFD keine
mainstream-partei sondern sie ist eine
Partei die sich aus vielem verabschiedet
was unsere demokratische verfasste
liberale und offene Gesellschaft
ausmacht und da setzt man Protest ja
vielleicht schauen wir uns noch mal was
an Oktober 22
sie haben dann Punkt
da hören wir den Landrat um die das
gerade geht Herrn Sesselmann wie er
sozusagen seine Weltsicht erklärt und
das ist in vielerlei Hinsicht sehr
interessant weil es ist der Sound den
ich zum Beispiel selber auf Reportagen
in Amerika immer wieder gehört habe und
fast bis ins Wort hinein die gleichen
ähnliche Formulierungen wir schauen uns
das mal kurz an
[Musik]
Hand wir haben jetzt die politisch
verursachte Energie diese
eine Wirtschaftskrise nach sich zieht
und diese
krisenzialkrise mit
Massenarbeitslosigkeit und Zusammenbruch
des Punktesystems und der Börsen wenn es
so weitergeht meine Damen und Herren der
great Reset lässt grüßen und wir sollen
als Bundesrepublik als marionettenstart
für die Politik als verlängerter Arm der
US-Politik dienen und dage
gen müssen wir uns wenden weil wir
müssen zunächst an unser Land zuerst
denken die grünen roten Kommunisten
haben abgewirtschaftet und wir
werden wissen dafür
länger da und der Bürger und
werden sie gesagt er hätte die Leute auf
dass das was ich meinte
voreinigte Reset
einmal sozusagen alles auf Null eine
politisch verursachte Energiekrise sehr
interessant als hätte es sozusagen den
den Angriff Russlands auf die Ukraine
nie gegeben eine politisch verursachte
Energiekrise
marionettenstat USA und so weiter und so
weiter grün rote Kommunisten die große
Inflation und dann das Trigger Wort
überhaupt
Massenarbeitslosigkeit und das ist sehr
ironisch weil Sonneberg sehr weit davon
entfernt ist Massenarbeitslosigkeit zu
haben ne ganz im Gegenteil machen viele
Unternehmen demnächst möglicherweise zu
oder kommen in Schwierigkeiten weil sie
keine Leute finden die für sie arbeiten
könnten das heißt wenn ich das höre dann
weiß ich doch wenn ich da wähle
also er bedient relativ klar
Verschwörungstheorien das muss man sagen
das hat man aber muss man auch dazu
sagen im Wahlkampf selbst selten gehört
da ist da viel schreibt vor allem mein
Kollege August Mode Sohn der viel im
Sonnenberg unterwegs war da ist da viel
moderater aufgetreten ich glaube weil
der AFD klar ist sie kann mit einem
relativ radikalen Stil aller Björn höcke
kann sie zwar eine relativ große
Wählerschaft erreichen aber auch eine
große Wählerschaft abschrecken das will
die AFD nicht deswegen tritt sie in
Wahlkämpfen auch im kommunalen
neuerdings Moderator auf deswegen sind
solche Töne seltener geworden wenn Sie
mich fragen warum Leute das trotzdem das
ist ja im Kopf ne also ich sag mal der
Brandstifter unter Biedermann ist da
oder der Wolf im Schaft wenn wir wollen
also wenn man das so hört wie geht's
ihnen Verpackungen wir erinnern Sie sich
nach der letzten Sendung haben wir beide
uns hinter den Kulissen die noch mal
darüber unterhalten auch welche
Diskussion sie auch zu Hause Freunde
Familie und so weiter haben genau über
diese Themen also ich glaube was was wir
erstmal feststellen müssen wenn wir
genau diese Kommentare hören dass es
dass es bestimmte narrative sind die
international verbinden und die
populistische Parteien verbinden auf dem
extrem rechnungsspektrum teilweise auch
auf extrem linken Spektrum und was mir
Sorgen bereitet ist das wir haben jetzt
eben den AFD Landrat wir haben einen
bestimmten Bereichen wo die AFD
sozusagen immer stärker wird wir haben
weil sie vielleicht einen einen kleinen
Punkt nach dem anderen nichts davon ist
vielleicht da ganz große damenbruch aber
es ist zu Drittel auch zu der zur
Normalisierung dieser Partei die aus
meiner Sicht völkisch nationalistisches
Gedankengut hat steht eben im Programm
sie ist offen rassistisch und wenn wir
das noch mal in vielleicht auch in den
europaweiten Vergleich ziehen haben wir
ja
Parteien mit ihnen nicht
rechtspopulistischer Ausrichtung
vielleicht nicht ganz so stark in diesem
völkischen nationalistischen aber
rechtspopulistische Ausrichtung die
Regierungsverantwortung gekommen sind
also schauen wir Ungarn schauen wir nach
Polen die FPÖ auch in Österreich und das
Problem was ich sehe ist das viele Jahre
in Schweden Demokraten und so weiter
eindeutig viele darauf hoffen dass wenn
diese Parteien erstmal in
Regierungsverantwortung kommen dass sie
ein zaubert werden und die Leute dann
merken okay die haben gar keine Konzepte
die haben keine Lösung das bringt gar
nichts und was wir bei diesen Ländern
sehen ist ja gerade das ist nicht so ist
sondern dass die sich mit einer sehr
dezidiert populistischen Regierungsweise
und nicht eine Politik sondern
Regierungsweise
Wahlen auch nachhaltig gewinnen können
oder zumindest wieder gewinnen können
auch wenn sie mal verloren haben und vor
allen Dingen und das sieht man natürlich
besonders stark wenn man nach Ungarn
schaut auch Dinge Polen auch wenn
vorhanden dass sie anfangs demokratische
System auszuhüllen und ich glaube wenn
wir diese Entwicklung
normalisieren ist das eben das Risiko
was wir tragen und das ist auch wieder
ein gesamtdeutsches Risiko und das ist
eben schon was wo ich mir einfach auch
Sorgen mache
also mir sind da zwei Punkte wichtig
denn es gibt eine gewisse Unehrlichkeit
finde ich in der Debatte die
Unehrlichkeit besteht darin dass wir in
Deutschland eigentlich ein Instrument
haben
umzugehen mit Parteien von denen wir der
Meinung sind die Gefährten die
Demokratie oder sie bekämpfen die
Demokratie dafür gibt's nämlich
Parteiverbotsverfahren in Deutschland
ist es möglich ähm stattgefunden hat
zweimal nur zweimal und das ist viele
Jahrzehnte her aber es gibt dieses
Instrument und auch diejenigen die bei
der AFD der Meinung sind sie
strebe eine Zerstörung der Demokratie an
haben bislang relativ selten dieses
Instrument versucht in die Hand zu
nehmen ja darüber müsste man sich auch
mal austauschen wenn man der Meinung ist
die AFD zerstört unsere System müssten
wir uns darüber unterhalten wird glaube
ich deswegen nicht gemacht weil man die
politischen Folgen fürchtet und der
zweite Punkt der mir wichtig ist
mir ist bei der AFD zu oft von einer
Protestpartei die rede ich glaube das
ist sie nicht ich erlebe diese Wähler
auch anders nicht mehr hat sich da was
verändert nicht nur nein also Sie haben
es vorhin schon gesagt Rechtspopulismus
sehen wir nicht nur in Deutschland nicht
nur in Ostdeutschland nicht nur in
Europa das sehen wir in den USA
Brasilien Italien Frankreich Polen
Ungarn wo auch immer sie hinschauen und
die Kinder diese These das sozusagen
Ostdeutschland eigentlich das normal ist
und Westdeutschland zumindest in Zeiten
in die AFD noch deutlich geringere
Zustimmungswerte hatte eigentlich
europaweit und sogar weltweit gesehen
die Ausnahmen ja genau naja gut wobei
eigentlich nimmt sich der besten immer
erst der Maßstab war aber das ist noch
meine andere
in den richtigen Kontext zu stellen und
ich finde das Rechtspopulisten die haben
ja einen Inhalt es gibt ja etwas wofür
die stehen die sind die stehen ja nicht
nur dafür dagegen zu sein sondern sie
sind sozusagen eine Reaktion auf die
Globalisierung und sie was sie tun ist
sie versuchen den Nationalstaat zu
stärken und sie versuchen äußere
Umstände wieder zurückzudrängen sie
versuchen sozusagen die politische
Globalisierung aufzuhalten indem sie
auch der Bevölkerung sagen wir können
wir stärken den Nationalstaat make
America great again Deutschland zuerst
deswegen Migration begrenzen deswegen
sich in der Ukraine zurückhalten alles
vor dem Hintergrund dass man sich
wünscht sozusagen die Macht beim
Nationalstaat zu bündeln und nicht
weiter in supra-nationale Institution
abzugeben oder ähnliches und ich finde
dass dass man sich mit diesem Kern schon
auseinandersetzen muss und sich auch
fragen muss wie kann man Wähler
erreichen die so denken das ist das eine
und das andere ist solange eine Partei
einfach demokratisch wählbar ist und
auch im Bundestag sitzt kann man dann
doch ehrlich gesagt niemandem wirklich
vorwerfen wenn es dann tut
also ich ernsthaft jetzt also wenn wir
wenn wir sagen dass das ist weiß ich
nicht faschistoid und das ist
Verfassungsschutz und das gehört
verboten und so weiter dann ist das eine
andere Situation aber wir persönlich
können das alle doof finden aber ich tue
mich wahnsinnig schwer jemanden dann
vorzuschreiben wo er sein Kreuz zu
machen hat aber das schreibt doch
niemals gibt
aber wir wir erheben uns sozusagen
moralisch und sagen das geht doch so auf
gar keinen Fall also ich finde das jetzt
wirklich schwierig sobald wir über die
AFD reden kommt Moral ins Spiel also das
finde ich schwierig ich habe hier
überhaupt nicht den Anspruch moralisch
besser zu sein weil ich Sozialdemokrat
bin ich erhebe mich nicht das habe ich
ich weiß nur auf die Konsequenz sondern
deswegen lehne ich zum Beispiel auch ein
Verbotsverfahren ab wer meint dass wir
das Problem der AFD dadurch lösen dass
wir diese Partei verbieten die wir ja
sowieso nicht verbieten können alleine
auf Antrag des Bundesrates des
Bundestages kann das
Bundesverfassungsgericht darüber
entscheiden und es ist ja mal richtig
schief gegangen bei der NPD daran werden
wir uns vielleicht noch erinnern sie ist
ja auch nicht verboten worden